so last week's episode was the first
episode of series 9 that I was
disappointed and did the second half of
this two-parter redeem it the Zygon
inversion this was a big improvement
over last week's episode I mean
especially at the conclusion and the
climax of this thing but I'm gonna get
to that cuz I want to end on the
positive note I do want to kind of deal
with my issues and my complaints first
cuz there are some for this episode and
most of the complaints I had about the
last episode still stand now I'm
actually gonna make an odd sort of
criticism and that I don't think I've
ever made about any Doctor Who episodes
ever this is the first two-parter that I
can think of that really should have
only been one episode because I think
about how well the ending of this story
worked and how as long as the build-up
to it was it wasn't necessary you could
have condensed and told the story of
this Zygon faction you know pushing
things in the direction of war in a more
condensed fashion and not have lost
anything actually what you would have
lost was a lot of the stuff that didn't
work nothing on the conceptual level
this is all execution issues like at
this point I still don't really buy the
reason that those icons didn't just kill
Clara I mean they offhandedly gave a
reason of oh we needed you for
information so okay that makes a tiny
bit of sense because you know if they've
got her in the pod and they've got the
you know the connection between her and
then the one imitating her that means
that they can get information from her
but they weren't using any information
from her in the previous episode it was
just leading a bunch of unit people down
there which they didn't need any of her
inside information to be able to do and
then immediately tell you the doctor
will she's dead I'm gonna try and kill
you they didn't try and extract
information out of her until the doctor
brought up the idea that she had
information so okay that's why you're
getting information out of her now but
why were you having her live up to that
point the sort of visualization of
things going on with Clara like from her
end being the one and kind of suspended
animation
and link to the xyron that was kind of
cool and I kind of liked that until we
got to the point where it's like what
Clarkin kind of manipulation she can
wink and she can text and all this other
stuff like okay well we've never even
had a hint that people who are being
duplicated and have that that connection
with the Saigon can affect as I got in
anyway so Clara just can because she's
because she's strong she's so special
and she could it's just these MarySue
tendencies with Clara that I'm really
not buying it also Kate first of all I
called very early on was like well
that's not because I got impersonating
her that's her and that was an easy call
but their explanation for how she got
out of this she shot those igon that's
it she did oh okay that is the lamest
way you could have covered that a would
have been better just to not make a
cliffhanger out of it like just to have
someone say oh I killed her and I'm
desire rather than showing the
cliffhanger part of it
Oh what was the real resolution how'd
she get out she pulled a gun and shot
him Wow
I've also got some nitpicky things about
the Zygons themselves really just the
visualization of them and it's not about
the inherent design I think the design
is fine but the point where one of them
turns into as I gone out in public and
runs yeah though that thing in full
daylight running around
honestly it brought to mind remembrances
of the absorbed all off it doesn't it
doesn't look great in broad daylight
but there's another thing too when this
comes down to I would just target up to
direction and the performers who are in
these suits because when they're in
Saigon for them all they ever do is this
yeah and then at that point they're not
characters they're just monsters and I
would have rather seen some of the
personality still bleeding through
because I mean they're impersonating
people but only physically these icons
have some sort of personality of their
own but that never comes through when we
see them as icons they're all just
completely interchangeable and and I
that strikes me as a really missed
opportunity still really happy with
Osgood and the way they resolve that I
I'm just gonna put on the record because
I'm sure there'll be plenty of debates
you know what she hooman what she does I
got she's the human to me it feels
obvious at this point because if the one
who had
personating clara is now the other
Osgood well the other one has to be
human because otherwise it's just too
Zygons and that doesn't work that's not
the balance not to mention the fact that
you know her glass is broken and the
doctor took them and fix them and put
the back well if she's as I Gong the
glasses aren't actually glasses they're
just part of her disguise they're a
physical part of her and she wouldn't
have been able to take them off and
break them and give them to the doctor
to fix but I still kind of like the fact
that the show did not say that outright
and especially with sort of the point
that it was making with all of that I
thought that was very cool I would have
liked to have seen I was gonna start to
travel in the TARDIS but I mean I by
this reasoning for why she won't
probably more than any other that would
have been a good companion but they
don't go in the TARDIS kind of character
because we've gotten a number of those
sporadically across the years but what
saves this story unequivocably the
ending that scene and the black vault
honestly is one of my new all-time
favorite Doctor Who scenes Capaldi is
brilliant in that scenes my favorite
thing I've seen him do just everything
about his performance just talking to
the Saigon and to Kate and the pain that
you see in his performances he's
recounting and you could see it in his
face remembering the things that he's
done these trying to stop them from
doing something that is just as bad and
it's even better in the greater context
of Doctor Who because how many times did
we see the doctor tennis doctor
especially did this a lot where he would
be in a situation with whoever the
villains were of the situation saying
you don't have to do this just stop and
I and I won't do anything I'll let you
go or whatever just don't do this and
they never listen they just do the thing
and then he has to destroy them and to
have it work because it Network works
finally it works and it's wonderful in
its glorious and it absolutely saves
this episode I would say that it saves
the whole story but again I I really
feel like the entire first episode of
this two-parter was not really necessary
you could have truncated and condensed
the the story and plot and logistics of
that in
to the first half of this episode and I
think as a single up so this would have
been brilliant this easily could have
been a new top ten episode of all time
for me but because it's got its ties to
the last week's which I still think is a
week episode regardless and there are
still lingering problems that I have
coming off the back of that into the
front half of this one but oh my god
when this episode gets good it is
brilliant and Capaldi is the best I've
ever seen him I'm and seriously as soon
as I am done recording this I'm gonna go
back and watch that scene again it is
that good so did you catch the Saigon
inversion what were your thoughts on it
whatever they were drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned